messieurs les premiers ministres
monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les ministres
mesdames et messieurs les membres du
bureau
mesdames et messieurs les députés chers
collègues
mesdames et messieurs
il arrive qu'évoquer le passé signifie
aussi engagé le présent et l'avenir
et c'est avec plaisir mais aussi une
grande émotion que je vous accueille
aujourd'hui pour célébrer Michel Rocard
le plus contemporain de nos grands
anciens le plus actuel de nos collègues
défunts
Michel Rocard
un style une voix une promesse
l'un de ces engagés pour qui la
politique n'était ni une carrière ni une
routine mais une mission un idéal
c'était les années 80 souvenez-vous le
Minitel et les envols d'Ariane les
premiers Restos du Coeur et Renaud
chantant société tu m'auras pas
et le président de la République en 1981
François Mitterrand avait fait
l'expérience d'une première cohabitation
à l'issue d'un duel Altan avec Jacques
Chirac il est réélu à la présidentielle
de 1988 et dissout l'Assemblée nationale
des législatives ont lieu une majorité
relative sort des urnes
à quelques mois près je n'étais pas
encore électrique j'enrage encore ce fut
en simple témoin que je vis défiler les
scrutins sur les écrans des cinq seules
chaînes de télévision disponibles à
l'école à l'époque
et que j'entendis nommer Michel Rocard
au poste de Premier ministre ce fut sur
les écrans que j'entendis des bribes de
sa splendide déclaration de politique
générale dont Jean-Pierre Darroussin va
tout à l'heure nous donner l'écho
le 29 juin 1988
c'était il y a bientôt 35 ans un propos
en avance sur la chronologie politique
française un discours qui annonçait la
fin
d'un bipolarisme stérile un espoir
incarné par cet homme intègre et droit
qui confiait
je rêve d'un pays où l'on se parle à
nouveau
autour de ce socialiste qui n'hésitait
pas à se dire social-démocrate un
nouveau monde politique se destinait
déjà
né le 23 août 1930 à Courbevoie Michel
Rocard avait connu la guerre à hauteur
d'adolescents sa mère Renée était
directrice d'un foyer de jeunes filles
son père Yves brillant professeur de
physique à l'École normale supérieure
résistant celui-ci allait après-guerre
devenir l'un des pères de la force de
dissuasion atomique française
le jeune Michel est inscrit à l'École
alsacienne
élevée dans la foi protestante il trouve
un premier engagement chez les
Éclaireurs Unionistes à 15 ans
ce scout découvre l'horreur
l'hôtel Lutetia siège de l'adver sous
l'Occupation et réquisitionné à la
Libération pour accueillir les rescapés
des camps de concentration
et Michel Rocard fait partie de l'équipe
des bénévoles qui viennent leur porter
secours
imagine-t-on sur le marbre et les épais
tapis sous les lourdes de tentures
rouges de ce luxueux palace ces ombres
faméliques ces échappés de la mort au
regard éperdu sous le choc des preuves
indissociables
un spectacle que le jeune regard
n'oubliera jamais condamnant toutes les
formes d'arbitraire et de violence
destiné par son père à une carrière
scientifique il choisit de s'orienter
vers les sciences politiques au futur
premier ministre sa famille coupe les
vivres il doit travailler au laboratoire
de l'École nationale supérieure pour
financer ses études et l'enfant de la
bourgeoisie se venge en yadérant aux
idées socialistes
un simple tourneur fraiseur militant
trots ancien des Brigades
Internationales monsieur Bertin lui
donne en quelques mois une formation
solide alliant théorie marxiste et
opposition ferme au communisme stalinien
l'anticolonialisme en ces années
d'après-guerre sera un autre
désengagement membre de la Fédération
nationale des étudiants socialistes
depuis secrétaire général de cette
organisation en 1954 Michel Rocard
condamne la guerre d'Indochine puis la
guerre d'Algérie
en 1956 il intègre l'École nationale
d'administration dont il sort inspecteur
des finances
sa promotion a beau se baptiser 18 juin
le retour au pouvoir du général de
Gaulle n'est pas pour lui motif
d'espérance
envoyez en Algérie il rédige secrètement
un rapport sur les camps de regroupement
ou des milliers d'indigènes sont parqués
dans des conditions indignes
révélées par la presse en 1959 ce
document cause de telles remous que le
premier ministre de l'époque Michel
Debré demande que Michel Rocard soit
révoqué de l'Inspection des finances
une mesure heureusement bloquée par un
grand résistant et de mon Michelet alors
ministre de la Justice
le haut fonctionnaire n'est pas plus en
phase avec la vieille SFIO de Guy Mollet
favorable au maintien du pacte colonial
il milite donc aux parties socialiste
autonomes qui devient en 1960 le Parti
socialiste unifié
cette unification affichée n'empêche pas
ce mouvement de rester pour le moins
confidentiel
critique du pouvoir et critique de
l'opposition font une approche originale
percutante inventive mais très
minoritaire dans le pays
longtemps plus tard Michel Rocard
évoquera non son nostalgique au
laboratoire politique où il fourbit son
programme
le PSE dira-t-il m'a permis de vivre une
existence extraordinaire mais purement
intellectuel
intègre et désintéressé et pourtant
marqué au saut d'un constat d'échec
enregistré électoral allemand
nous n'avons eu au mieux que 4 députés à
la fois
à 37 ans Michel Rocard prend la
direction du parti
battu une première fois au législative
de 1967 il se présente de nouveau après
la dissolution qui suit la crise de 1968
le PSU a alors pour soutien et figures
tutélaire Pierre Mendès France et c'est
un beau passage de témoin qui s'opère
quand le vétéran de la Troisième
République le républicain élu député à
l'âge de 25 ans le combattant de la
France Libre le président du conseil de
1954 qui avait tenté de rénover la
République de l'Intérieur soutient en
1968 la candidature du technocrate
moderniste
ce jeune fondue haut fonctionnaire n'a
pas hésité à renoncer à la mission
importante qui lui avait été dévolu au
sein de la commission des contes de la
nation alors que d'autres préfèrent les
sécurités près du pouvoir il a choisi de
prendre une part active à notre combat
pour une démocratie nouvelle et un
socialisme moderne en votant pour Michel
Rocard vous voterez pour la politique du
renouveau et du progrès écrit Pierre
Mendès France sur le programme de son
poulain
ce soutien ne suffit pas aux candidats
Rocard pour l'emporter contre la vague
gaulliste qui fait suite à la crise mais
la politique est pleine de surprises
puisque l'année suivante une élection
partielle lui permet enfin d'entrer à
l'Assemblée nationale où le jeune député
PSU des Yvelines siège parmi les non
inscrits
1969 c'est surtout la démission du
général de Gaulle l'élection
présidentielle la seule en fait à
laquelle Michel Rocard a pu concourir
avec l'émergence de François Mitterrand
Vérité Justice responsabilité
sur ce slogan et sur cette base il
intervient sur les questions économiques
et financières quand il ne dépose pas
des propositions de loi innovantes comme
celle du 4 octobre
1972 qui visait à permettre aux
consommateurs de s'associer pour porter
plainte contre des institutions ou des
entreprises sur le modèle des classes
actions
anglo-saxonne une proposition de loi
transpartisanes au début de cette
législature lui a donné raison
au législatives de 1973 il est battu
après une partie du PSU il se rapproche
du Parti socialiste profondé par
François Mitterrand et on devient l'un
des secrétaires nationaux aux
municipales de 1977 il est élu maire de
Conflans-Sainte-Honorine dès le premier
tour sur un projet de démocratie
participative
le voici donc solidement ancré dans les
Yvelines pour les législatives de 1978
dans sa profession de foi Michel Rocard
synthétise habilement problématique
locale et nationale le candidat déplore
que
ce qui faisait le charme de cette partie
du département c'est forêts et la vallée
de la Seine a dû céder du terrain sous
les coups d'un urbanisme sauvage mise au
service des promoteurs et des profits
capitalistes partisans d'un socialiste
auto-gestionnaire il combat le pouvoir
du capitalisme et ses firme
multinationales les promoteurs sans
scrupules et la tutelle étouffante de
l'État
là encore dans le contexte des années 70
Michel Rocard marque sa différence les
questions environnementales le préoccupe
autant que le problème de l'emploi et
les tatismes à tout craint n'est pas la
solution pour lui la démocratie doit
être plus diffuse et décentralisée les
citoyens doivent avoir leur mot à dire à
tous les échelons la France qu'il
appelle de ses vœux est adulte et
responsable
arrivé en tête au premier tour d'un
petit millier de voix contre le candidat
gaulliste il l'emporte au second tour
par près de 53% des suffrages exprimés
ce succès personnel ne suffit pas
toutefois à renverser la majorité la
gauche donnée favorite au plan national
reste dans l'opposition et Michel Rocard
ne se fait pas que des amis dans son
camp lorsqu'ils déclare
un certain style de politique un certain
archaïsme sont condamnés
il n'est pas toujours très payant
d'avoir raison trop tôt François
Mitterrand ses amis ses alliés
parviennent à conserver la main Michel
Rocard sera certes ministre d'État
ministre du Plan et de l'aménagement du
territoire de 1981 à 1983 ministre de
l'Agriculture de 1983 à 1985 avant de
redevenir député en 1986 mais il faudra
attendre juin 1988 pour que ce premier
ministre d'un style nouveau puisse
donner sa pleine mesure
en trouvant les voix du dialogue en
Nouvelle-Calédonie d'abord et c'est
aussi en son hommage que j'ai tout
récemment inauguré une salle Jacques
Lafleur Jean-Marie tshibao au Palais
Bourbon en créant le revenu minimum
d'insertion votez presque à l'unanimité
aussi
en faisant accepter la contribution
sociale généralisée en faisant passer le
budget de la Nation en réformant la
Poste la France Télécom quitte à
recourir à ce troisième alinéa de
l'article 49 qu'il avait critiqué jadis
et dont il fuse au fond
un usage constitutionnel et responsable
à l'écoute des aspirations de la société
civile Michel Rocard a ouvert son
gouvernement à des personnalités
indépendantes et c'est attachées à
rechercher des compromis comme il le
disait lui-même un amendement de la
majorité n'est pas un crime de lèse
majesté
un amendement de l'opposition n'est pas
a priori légitime ni dépourvu de sens
national
avec le précieux concours de Guy
Carcassonne son conseiller aux Relations
avec le Parlement il construit des
majorités à géométrie variables obtenant
alternativement et quelquefois
conjointement le vote des centriste et
des communistes
c'est aussi Michel Rocard qu'on retrouve
à l'initiative de la Conférence de La
Haye le 11 mars 1989 elle réunit 24
chefs d'État et de gouvernement pour
évoquer enfin la protection de
l'atmosphère et c'est à raison de cette
sensibilité écologique qu'il deviendra
plus tard notre première ambassadeur
d'épaules
dernier dossier sensible auquel est
associé le nom de Michel Rocard la Corse
il suit là encore avoir des mots forts
pour se hisser à la hauteur des enjeux
il porta ce territoire dans son cœur et
depuis sa disparition le 2 juillet 2016
s'est cendres repose à Montignies
il faudrait beaucoup plus de temps pour
évoquer de manière exhaustive la vie et
l'action de ce grand réformateur à qui
nous devons beaucoup
la plaque que je vais bientôt dévoiler
n'est qu'un modeste hommage à celui dont
on pourrait dire avec Milan Kundera
se souvenir de son passé le porter
toujours avec soi c'est peut-être la
condition nécessaire pour conserver
comme on dit
l'intégrité de son moi
Michel Rocard
l'intégrité fait homme retrouve
symboliquement sa place dans notre
hémicycle et je vous remercie pour lui
pour sa famille d'être présent si
nombreux à cette occasion
[Applaudissements]
bonjour mesdames messieurs
deux discours de Michel Rocard ont été
choisis pour
entendre un petit peu sa voix
aujourd'hui dans ces dans cette émission
le premier discours est un discours qui
a été écrit alors que Michel Rocca était
donc candidat en juin 1968 sous les
couleurs du PSU comme vous l'avez
rappelé
et Michel Rocard et battu
et il écrit il fait un discours et cette
profession de foi est alors très
revendicative
le mouvement de Mai 68 à Clermont montré
par son ampleur que la genèse du pays et
les travailleurs ne voulaient plus d'un
pouvoir soumis aux forces capitalistes
grâce à ce mouvement
la classe ouvrière a souvent obtenu des
avantages matériels vainement réclamés
depuis des années et ne faisons
d'ailleurs que compenser tardivement les
résultats de la politique rétrograde du
gaullisme
mais
déjà l'État et le patronat s'apprête à
reprendre par le jeu de l'inflation ce
qu'ils ont dû céder aux travailleurs
les revendications matérielles des
travailleurs ne seront réellement
garantis
leur exigence de pouvoir ne sera
satisfaite que par un gouvernement de
transition vers le socialisme
appuyez sur l'ensemble des forces
populaires pour les objectifs suivants
mettre l'économie au service des
travailleurs
transformer l'université
assuré la liberté de l'information
lutter contre l'impérialisme préparer
avec des comités populaires à tous les
échelons les institutions d'une société
socialiste et démocratique
20 ans plus tard
vient le temps des responsabilités et
dans sa déclaration de politique
générale le 29 juin 1988 Michel Rocard
présente sa conception de l'action
gouvernementale
aucune formation ne détient la majorité
absolue dans cette assemblée
les socialistes
dont j'ai la fierté d'être ils sont
majoritaires mais de manière seulement
relative
ainsi en ont décidé des Français
notre retard dès lors n'est pas
simplement de nous en accommoder
d'essayer tant bien que mal de
rassembler des voix au hasard des
projets
les Français ont exprimé ce qu'il
voulait leur volonté et notre loi et
j'entends l'appliquer
cela signifie en premier lieu que la
politique conduite sera conforme aux
valeurs qui font les socialistes
la tolérance la justice le progrès la
solidarité
tous mes amis qui siègent sur ces bancs
ils sont acquis mais ils savent aussi
que les idées qu'ils défendent ne sont
jamais si belles
si rayonnante
que quand elle va pour tous
nos priorités ne sont pas celles d'une
moitié de la France contre l'autre
moitié
mais celle de tous les Français
défaire ce que les autres ont fait faire
ce que d'autres d'effront voilà bien le
type de politique dont les électeurs ne
veulent plus
nous ne demanderons à personne de nous
rejoindre par intérêt ni de trahir ses
convictions
tous les socialistes qui sont ici
entendent bien le rester
et nous comprenons donc que d'autres qui
sont centrés communistes libéraux ou
gaulliste n'envisage pas non plus de
renoncer à l'être
mais avec ceux qui seront ouverts nos
différences s'accorderont sans que nul
n'ait besoin de renoncer à ce qu'il est
c'est là ce que veulent les Français et
c'est à leur égard que chacun devra donc
prendre ses responsabilités
j'ai pris les miennes dans le règlement
du dossier néo-calédonien en me refusant
à toute polémique partisane à l'égard de
mes prédécesseurs en informant et
associant ceux des responsables
politiques de l'opposition qui l'ont
bien voulu
à convictions anciennes
fidélité maintenue mais attend nouveau
pratique résolument nouvelle
mesdames et messieurs je me suis dans
cette déclaration soigneusement abstenue
de toute mise en cause de toute
dénonciation
rien ne serait plus contraire à la
passion de la France unie que nous fait
partager François Mitterrand
rien en effet ne serait moins conforme
aux besoins des Français
en tant que responsable
mon propos est sans doute austère en
tant que citoyen et tout simplement en
tant qu'homme mon enthousiasme est
entier mon espoir est intact je rêve
d'un pays
où l'on se parle à nouveau
je rêve des villes où les tensions sont
moindres
je rêve d'une politique où l'on soit
attentif à ce qui est dit plutôt qu'à
qui le dit
je rêve tout simplement
d'un pays ambitieux
dont tous les habitants redécouvrent le
sens du dialogue
pourquoi pas de la fête
et de la liberté
je suis de ceux qui croient au plus
profond de même que la liberté
c'est toujours la liberté de celui qui
pense autrement
chérir la liberté de cette manière là
c'est au tour des thèmes que je vous ai
proposé la réconciliation la solidarité
les chemins de l'avenir
construire un nouvel espoir pour que
vive les Français et pour que vive la
France
[Applaudissements]